recordáis el manifiesto comunista y su
famoso comienzo de un fantasma recorre
europa pues bien a diferencia de lo que
planteaban marx y engels en nuestros
días no es el fantasma del comunismo el
que se cierne sobre europa sino el de la
xenofobia y la extrema derecha
[Música]
hace 70 años el racismo y el
nacionalismo redujeron europa a cenizas
hoy algunas de estas ideas vuelven a
estar de moda pero puede que os
preguntéis quiénes son realmente estos
partidos de extrema derecha
qué fuerza tienen qué es lo que quieren
en este vídeo hablamos de la nueva
derecha que ha brotado en el 'viejo
continente' vamos a ello
[Música]
francia holanda dinamarca alemania la
extrema derecha está creciendo como la
espuma a lo largo y ancho de toda europa
casi podemos decir que españa y portugal
son las únicas excepciones a esta ola de
fanatismo y radicalidad aunque cuidado
con los términos porque tal y como nos
contó fonseca en un pasado vídeo cada
vez resulta más difícil determinar dónde
queda a la derecha y donde la izquierda
[Música]
como sabéis amigos de visual política en
los últimos años el debate político ha
cambiado hemos pasado de escoger entre
más o menos a intervención a decidir
entre globalización sí o globalización
no por eso no es extraño que estos
partidos de extrema derecha recojan
muchas posturas tradicionales de la
izquierda como el proteccionismo la
estatalización de sectores económicos o
más planes de bienestar es curioso pero
por ello la extrema derecha está
quitándole votos sobre todo a los
partidos de izquierdas y cuidado porque
en 2017
hay varias elecciones importantes
a holanda finlandia y como ocurrió en
las de diciembre de 2016 en austria
estos partidos van a tener mucho
protagonismo e influencias dicen que soy
un lobo con piel de cordero pues bien se
equivocan no lo soy no tengo ningún tipo
de piel y desde luego la victoria de
trump les ha dado energía mucha energía
en visual político prestaremos mucha
atención a estos procesos y los
analizaremos uno a uno pero hoy vamos a
ver una radiografía de esta nueva
extrema derecha
claves políticas de la extrema derecha
en europa
pero qué piensan estos partidos que
persiguen que les une pues aunque no
podamos decir que sean todos idénticos
sí que tienen algunas características
comunes en primer lugar son muy
nacionalistas y recelosos de la
soberanía nacional por ello defienden
según los casos o abandonar la unión
europea o transformarla acabando con el
proyecto comunitario de integración
política es decir quieren limitar la
unión a un acuerdo estrictamente
económico ya os podéis imaginar amigos
que con el break it lanzaron fuegos
artificiales son españoles europa la que
ha muerto es la unión europea la que se
tambalea por otro lado y con la
excepción del ukip y el partido de la
libertad de holanda estos partidos
defienden el proteccionismo y que sea el
estado el que marque el rumbo económico
vamos que de liberales no tienen nada
por último el punto tal vez más
importante consideran las diferencias
culturales y la inmigración como una
amenaza para la identidad nacional
europa debería cumplir con sus valores
judeocristianos esos valores deberían
ser preservados y protegidos para las
próximas generaciones
y no sólo eso para estos partidos la
inmigración causa también inseguridad
pérdida de puestos de trabajo y
muchísimos costes para el estado por
ello al hablar de inmigración es muy
habitual que estos partidos utilicen de
forma peyorativa el término invasión
aunque por supuesto ésta no existe en
absoluto fijaros el número de
inmigrantes en toda la unión europea es
de aproximadamente 34 millones de
personas pueden parecer muchas pero
representan menos del 7 por ciento de la
población un porcentaje muy inferior al
de países como australia nueva zelanda o
canadá pero menos de la mitad
aunque claro los datos no siempre
cuentan zonas como sajonia en alemania
donde apenas hay inmigrantes son grandes
caladeros de votos para este tipo de
partidos de extrema derecha precisamente
por el miedo a la inmigración o sea el
miedo a lo desconocido es verdad en
algunos casos hay problemas graves de
integración como ocurre por ejemplo con
la población musulmana que por sí mismo
supone otra de las grandes bazas para
estos partidos y mi pregunta es queréis
en esta ciudad y en holanda más o menos
marroquíes dijo en la haya
convocar pero sería muy injusto
generalizar y va a analizar un problema
tan complejo por cierto tal vez pueda
sorprendernos pero hoy hay menos
terrorismo en europa que las décadas de
los 70 los 80 y los 90
no lo digo para enviar el problema que
hoy sufrimos ni muchísimo menos pero
frente a lo que podamos sentir esta es
la realidad
en cualquier caso amigos combatir el
odio con políticas que surgen desde el
propio odio no suele traer buenos
resultados y personalmente no creo que
aislarse del mundo sea la mejor solución
ni siquiera una solución bien vista sus
características comunes es posible que
os estáis preguntando pero quiénes son
estos partidos así que veamos caso por
caso los partidos de extrema derecha que
más influencia política están ganando en
europa
los países bajos
el partido por la libertad de geert
wilders es ya el primero en intención de
voto y no es que sus políticas sean
precisamente moderadas este partido se
presenta ante el público con la misión
ojo de des islamizar holanda y cómo lo
quiere lograr pues cerrando todas las
mezquitas prohibiendo el corán y viendo
el velo islámico y cerrando las
fronteras acá el canto a todas las
personas musulmanas su otra propuesta
estrella como no abandonar la unión
europea para recobrar la soberanía
nacional y la unión europea se ha
quedado con la soberanía de holanda que
están a cargo ahora son los emisarios o
por quienes no conoce nadie en holanda y
peor a quienes nadie ha elegido
el frente nacional es sin lugar a dudas
el decano de los partidos de extrema
derecha en europa tiene su origen en la
época de de gaulle y la independencia de
argelia en 1962 que provocó un cabreo
monumental en gran parte de la población
francesa de hecho para luchar contra la
independencia de argelia a algunos altos
mandos militares y políticos formaron lo
que se conoció como la organización del
ejército secreto un grupo terrorista que
además de actuar en argelia y en francia
trató incluso de acabar con la vida del
propio general de gaulle el grupo había
realizado en sólo un año de vida más de
700 acciones armadas había convertido a
de gaulle en su principal objetivo pues
bien es de esos mimbres de donde surge
el frente nacional un partido de corte
xenófobo e internacionalista
tú qué es lo que quiere bueno creo que
prácticamente lo podéis adivinar luchar
contra la inmigración abandonar el euro
salirse de la unión europea y apostar
por políticas proteccionistas
ahí le vert
arif texas rangers si amigos de hecho la
política económica que propone es
bastante de izquierdas e incluso quieren
subir los impuestos en francia que ella
es uno de los países con más impuestos
del mundo claro que a la vista de los
acontecimientos con todos los atentados
ya han sacudido a francia últimamente no
nos puede extrañar que este partido
dirigido por marie le pen esté luchando
por ser la primera fuerza política del
país que asignada
austria
en diciembre de 2016 el fbi liderado por
norbert hoffer bajo el lema austria y
los austriacos primero se quedó a cinco
puntos de ganar las presidenciales y
convertirse atentos en el primer país
europeo gobernado por la extrema derecha
desde 1945
jover y lfp o repiten el patrón típico
prometen cuidar del estado del bienestar
evitando que los inmigrantes puedan
acceder a él apuesta por fronteras
cerradas defiende la familia tradicional
y se declara euroescéptico no defienden
abandonar de entrada la unión europea
pero si quieren que ésta abandone su
carácter político y en cualquier caso
apuestan por celebrar un referéndum
sobre la pertenencia a la misma para que
sea el propio pueblo austríaco el que
decida si seguir o marcharse su
influencia ya se nota en austria el 77%
de los encuestados afirman tener una
mala imagen sobre los refugiados
en el caldo de cultivo que generan estos
partidos tiene consecuencias
[Música]
alemany la alternativa para alemania es
un partido político euroescéptico creado
hace muy poco en 2013 este es un partido
un tanto diferente porque aunque entre
sus filas hay verdaderos radicales su
origen está más ligado a la crisis a las
dudas hacia el euro y al recelo con los
países del sur de europa eso sí no
perdieron la oportunidad de aprovechar
la crisis de los refugiados para sacar
rédito político ahí se produjo el salto
al populismo que a decir verdad de
momento les está funcionando muy bien
con la victoria del presi han sido los
grandes triunfadores aunque la verdad es
que l'équipe es un partido bastante
peculiar su base tiende a ser más
liberal que proteccionista y en buena
medida se declaran herederos políticos
de margaret thatcher su obsesión es y ha
sido la unión europea pero claro tampoco
han dudado en tirar del discurso
antiinmigración para ganar adeptos y
aunque estos son los más destacados no
son ni mucho menos los únicos por
ejemplo en dinamarca el partido popular
danés fue el segundo partido más votado
en el gobierno finés están los
verdaderos finlandeses que tienen ideas
similares a las que hemos visto en el
vídeo y los demócratas de suecia la
derecha radical sueca tienen aún mucho
recorrido por delante y respecto a
europa del este y europa central bueno
casi que mejor lo dejamos para otro
vídeo bueno cuál es tu opinión son estos
partidos una amenaza como se puede
derrotar su discurso esperamos vuestras
respuestas si os ha gustado el vídeo
dadle a like y por cierto si queréis ver
qué ocurre en un país sin inmigración no
os perdáis el caso de japón
y haciendo clic aquí un saludo y hasta
la próxima amigos
[Música]